i am kamala harris my pronouns are she
and her i'm a woman sitting at the table
wearing a blue suit the oxford
dictionary describes intersectionality
as a study of the way race class and
gender have been used for discrimination
and caused disadvantages in our society
but it's hard to ignore the fact that
the people who keep pushing so hard for
intersectionality
on us and on our kids whether it's in
the form of critical race theory or it's
the vice president who just heard there
talking about you know
her blue suit these are the people who
are some of the most advantaged on the
planet like kamala harris like cabinet
members including p buddha judge and
four-star admirals like rachel levine
and elected members of the house of
representatives and it's not just the
government we can't forget that all
these fortune 500 companies supported
black lives matter with a lot of cash
now instead of focusing again on the
unique talents and achievements that
come from individual traits that make
you and i unique what these people want
to do is wash all that away for the
benefit of the state and their political
power grabs let's talk to someone now
who knows exactly what's going on and
welcome in dave rubin host of the reuben
report author of don't burn this country
as always dave great to see you
john nice to be with you uh i am going
by the pronoun sith lord and decepticon
leader and uh my disability is a mild
kink in my neck slept a little funny
last night that makes you special and uh
you know we talked i think you you
shared my tweet of the uh
disability pride month flag they just
changed it last year what do you think
is really going on here
well
they seem to think that if you can
whittle us all down to the things that
matter the least about us and then we
can combine those things that then we
will have something stronger and of
course that's completely the reverse
nobody watching this wants to be judged
on whether they're white or black or gay
or straight or able-bodied or disabled
or anything else these months that come
and go whether it's pride month or
disability month or disabled pride month
or whatever god knows what is next they
mean nothing other than this bizarre
corporate virtue signaling whether it's
walking into target and being slammed
with he him her shirts which they had at
target during june by the way you know
what they don't have there they've got
all the shirts they've got the you know
the gay crayons and the rest of it they
don't have any customers there because
there's never i've been to target i go
to target a lot i just moved here in
florida have to pick up a lot of stuff
and there's never any people buying
those things so it's corporate virtue
signaling nobody that's buying their
crayons for their kids care about queer
this or trans that or anything else they
care if i don't know do the crayons work
how about that that would be something
um but but this is what the left has
left and it's why so many people are
seeing through the nonsense anymore it's
it's the complete reverse of what martin
luther king would have wanted for his
children of course being judged on the
content of their character rather than
the color of their skin and we just have
to keep pushing through because it's
just going to get more bizarre you know
you showed that kamala harris clip and
it's like try to imagine her in a
meeting with say i don't know president
xi from china and saying what her
pronouns are and what color pant suit
she's wearing i i don't speak chinese
but i would imagine it would be pretty
hilarious what he would whisper to the
guy next to him yes when when our world
leaders are sitting down for bylats and
actually starting that way then we will
all know it's time to run for the hills
and find a bunker someplace
and this is a question i think a lot of
people have is is this the future of
every meeting we have where we have to
sit down identify ourselves and our
pronouns and
yeah this is not a future in my meetings
john i have two companies we're not
going to be doing it at my companies i
suspect you guys aren't going to be
doing it over at uh newsmax but yeah i
think it is it is i mean joking aside it
is the future of sort of blue state
corporate that conglomerate thing that
it has become this will be where if you
have a company that is in california
you're going to hire unqualified people
based on their pronouns and their
disabilities and the rest of it you will
no longer make good products because you
will have not hired the cream of the
crop you will have based uh you will
have hired based on other attributes
that are irrelevant to the job you will
make a worse product you will sell less
things uh whatever regardless of what
business you're in uh you'll be a worse
haircutter or a worse plumber or you'll
sell less widgets uh and then there'll
be another part of the country which
will be where we are in florida and in
some of the red states where people will
not do these things will not care about
what your pronunc pronouns are and guess
what people will flourish and florida if
that's the case we'll continue to gain
congressional seats in california and
new york will lose them
but i digress
one other topic too with you dave i
think two more actually i want to talk
about clarence thomas he's stepping down
as a lecturer at george washington
university
this comes after students there have
completely lost it the daily mail says
justice thomas informed gw law that he
is unavailable to co-teach a
constitutional law seminar
this fall he's been doing it for 11
years and i don't blame him for doing
this
um why go someplace where you're not
wanted the students there do not like
clarence thomas they don't want to be
called the whatever they're you know
they're changing their name now because
they're no you can't say colonials
anymore that's offensive
and this is i i think
unfortunate but the right move for
clarence thomas
yeah you know everyone has their own
threshold for the nonsense and clarence
thomas has put up with more nonsense
over the years than most right i mean at
his at his hearing when he was uh gonna
become a supreme court justice at the
confirmation hearing it was joe biden
then senator joe biden uh who was
basically trying to destroy clarence
thomas he's gone through you know 35
plus years of having the machine try to
destroy him of being called all sorts of
the worst things because he's a
conservative who just happens to be
black and i would say it's it's a darn
shame for those students and the other
faculty because whether you agree with
every one of justice thomas's decisions
are not very few people including if you
just listened to some of the words from
ruth bader ginsburg from way back when
or even elena kagan in the last couple
weeks they they know that he knows his
stuff they may not fully believe uh in
his judicial philosophy but this is
someone who everyone could learn from
and the fact that the protesters
whatever level of headache that he was
dealing with by showing up there uh he
just doesn't want to deal with it
anymore i wish him nothing but the best
and i hope he stays on the supreme court
for a long time obviously but yeah
everyone has a tolerance limit on the
headache and the nonsense and being
yelled at and all the rest of the stuff
and he'll probably just write some more
books or yeah you know do some other
interesting things and he would think
some some overconfident college student
with a lot of hubris we want to go into
clarence thomas's class and kind of lock
horns with them a little bit of course
no they they just can't even they cannot
even have them on the on campus because
they're triggered about it uh last topic
for you dave brittany griner and there's
this uh supposed prisoner swap with the
russians we're going to trade brittany
greiner
and paul wellin who's a marine who's
been locked up there in russia for a
long time for a guy named victor bout
who is known as the merchant of death
maybe a player to be named later i don't
know but this victor black guy is a bad
dude
you got my joke i was going to throw in
two draft picks
yeah this whole thing is this whole
thing is extremely bizarre i mean really
really bizarre so she's been held there
now for months and months it barely made
the media until the last couple days
and you know let's just i know everyone
watching this knows about the endless
double standard we see with all these
things but of course if it was a
republican administration dare i say uh
donald trump people would have been
going crazy here is this black lesbian
professional basketball player who's
being held in russia this is the worst
thing ever but somehow when it happened
under the biden administration nobody
cared now we're doing this odd deal
there's something else going on here i
don't know what it is uh but something
feels very very off about this whole
thing yeah we get brittany griner back
who didn't want to kneel for the pledge
of allegiance or for the national anthem
and russia gets back
this weapons deal it doesn't seem like a
fair trade to me of course want brittany
grinder home you want paul welling home
whatever it takes um
but you wonder if the vine
administration may be getting played
here on this deal dave rubin listen i
think we could have thrown in megan
rappanau we could have thrown in rachel
levine we could have thrown in buddha
judge marin jean-pierre i'm going to put
a package together see what what i can
move here okay and isn't edward snowden
still over there does he want to come i
don't know we could we could go on and
on great to see you dave rubin we'll see
you on the internet
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell